hey everyone i'm john coogan and today i
want to talk about a really cool new app
i've been beta testing
it's called play byte and it's an
interesting blend between a social
networking site
and a video game the product is still in
early development
but the team is running the most
effective beta test that i've ever seen
so i wanted to share what i thought that
they were doing well in the hopes that
other companies would follow in their
footsteps
the company was founded by a friend of
mine kyle russell who was working for
andreas and horowitz while i was working
on soylent so we got to know each other
through board meetings and twitter
conversations
and i've been hoping that he was going
to launch his own thing for a while now
he had described what he was building a
couple times publicly
but it wasn't until he invited me to
join the beta that it really clicked for
me
here's how the app works currently upon
logging in you are presented with a
pretty standard feed
similar to instagram or tick tock but
instead of static content like pictures
and videos
everything in the feed is a game when
you click on the play button
the game starts and you try and steer
your characters towards some sort of
goal
each game is simple usually taking only
a few seconds to finish
but what makes them really interesting
is that they are all community created
instead of developing a fictional world
with plot lines and character designs
the playbite team has released a highly
flexible sandbox game engine
that allows anyone to make one of these
games in just a few clicks
the game creation process is really easy
to pick up and run with
there are just a few different types of
objects that you can place around the
level
things like where the player starts
where the end goal is along with hazards
and collectibles
here's a level that i built in about
five minutes using screenshots of
youtube icons
where it gets really interesting is in
the tags field each object in the level
can be customized with tags that let you
change the collision behavior
on-screen appearance movement patterns
and physics like gravity
the implementation is simple enough that
you don't really need to read anything
to get started
but it's deep enough that you can still
create fairly complex interactions and
tell a bit of a story within the game
that you create the first byte that i
saw that really got this point across
was called amazon delivery training
the game seems simple enough your
character is an amazon package
and the goal appears to be at the top of
the stairs but when you move your
character to the top of the stairs
you die and you have to start the level
over it's only after you deliver the
package to the bottom of the stairs that
you win
clearly whoever made this is frustrated
with their recent deliveries and the
game conveys that message in a really
clever way
playbite is an interesting position
currently sandbox games that focus on
user-created content
have a rich history simcity was one of
the first to find success in this genre
in 1989
and since then the category has grown
significantly secondlife
launched its online virtual world in
2003 and is still active today with
nearly one million active users
and while a million users is pretty good
minecraft has over a hundred million
users
and was sold to microsoft for 2.5
billion dollars
it's also become the best-selling video
game of all time with over 200 million
copies sold
and as if that wasn't impressive enough
for the sandbox category
roblox another sandbox game with even
more customization options
recently passed 164 million monthly
active
users with over half of all children
aged under 16 in the united states
playing the game
roblox is now on the cusp of ipo'ing and
should be worth over 8 billion
when it does crazy the scale of these
sandbox games is truly incredible
and i think this type of scale is really
only achievable with a sandbox approach
the cost of producing new content on an
ongoing basis is extremely high
and you'll never be able to satisfy
every niche community
with a user-driven approach you never
have to split your player base with a
controversial design decision
since the player is always in charge of
their own design
and that's what's interesting about the
play by beta even though the number of
games is a bit limited at the moment
they are laser focused on building great
tools to let anyone create fun and
engaging experiences
undoubtedly the best content will come
from the community not the playbite team
directly
but attracting creators to a new
platform can be extremely challenging
it's a classic chicken and egg problem
no one will use the app if it's devoid
of content
but playbite's beta program is solving
this problem in a really intelligent way
they set up a waitlist form on their
landing page where they collect emails
then they slowly onboard people to the
app in waves
simultaneously the team is creating
games on the platform using the creation
tools that they are actively developing
this not only helps them understand the
user experience but also populates the
app
so that when beta testers arrive it's
not a ghost town
getting a few people to try your new app
in beta is nothing new
but the playbite team has taken it a
step further by setting up a discord
server
where all the beta testers can chat
about their experience and give feedback
directly to the developers
they have channels for feature requests
bug reports and a feed of all the new
levels that get published
this direct communication is critical
when you're iterating on your minimum
viable product and working towards
product market fit
at many startups early adopter feedback
gets relegated to a monthly survey
or occasional user interviews that
create a much longer feedback cycle
i think every early stage startup should
be using a tool like discord to help
facilitate direct customer interaction
during a beta testing period
but that's not the only thing i think
playbite has done really well
they also clearly understand the
importance of keeping beta testers
engaged
i can't tell you how many apps i've
tried once only to never open the app
again
it's natural for some beta testers to
drop out after their first experience
but the team is fighting this by sending
concise email updates with info about
what's changed in the app
when they push a big update the first
time i tried the app
i played a few games but i didn't create
anything and i never came back
but once i got the email about the
latest release i tried the app again
and then i found some new content that i
liked even more which led me to create
my own byte
running a successful beta test requires
finding a balance between letting your
testers drop
out if they genuinely aren't interested
in your product
and annoying everyone with endless
updates asking them to try the same
version once again
if you haven't made any significant
changes the playbite team is doing a
great job of not being annoying
while still encouraging testers to try
each iteration and give feedback
the last thing i love about the playbite
beta test is how clearly you can see
that the core game creation mechanic is
their main priority
just since i've been testing they've
already added a bunch of really
significant features to make the games
better
but they still don't have a password
reset button i love this
many entrepreneurs don't want to launch
until they have a shiny brand with a
beautiful landing page
and have checked all the boxes that a
product manager at facebook would check
for a big tech
product launch this is a disastrous
approach
and we all just witnessed what happens
when this is taken to an extreme with
quibby
instead of building quivi iteratively by
first launching a single show
with a small audience and then
collecting feedback they raised nearly
two billion dollars before launching and
ran
headfirst into a bunch of obvious
problems when they finally got into
consumers hands
so i have two main takeaways from this
first if you like games at all
you should definitely sign up to be part
of the beta program at playbite.io
and second if you're an entrepreneur
working on an early stage product
you should copy as much of the play by
beta program as you can
i think it's a great pattern for product
development and i genuinely believe that
building products in this way
will lead to a greater chance of success
but let me know what you
think are there any particularly great
beta programs that you've been a part of
leave me a comment so i can check them
out and if you enjoyed the video please
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching